kyle gibson on the mound today
for the rangers 16 starts undefeated
opponents batting average at 202 you
have to like what we're about to see
locked in get the rhythm going you want
to disrupt it if you're
on the offensive side but due rips a
single to right
[Applause]
first hit of the series rbi chance for
robbie grossman
up the middle of the base hit but due
rounds third he will score
easily and robbie grossman has himself
an rbi single here in the first to give
the tigers a one-nothing lead
oh he gets a swing of the miss and
strikes out haas
second out of inning and he was able to
whittle down
a 135 era here's the swing of the miss
and he strikes out
candelario to end the inning but detroit
gets a run and makes him work
rangers face the 24 year old native of
springville alabama casey mize
popped it up zach short
takes care of it and eli white is out
ball to first jonathan scope will take
it himself
sharply to third nice play by candelario
that's a nine pitch first inning for
casey mize and he retires the rangers
one two three
two and two did he go yes he did short
strikes out that's a third strikeout for
gibson this afternoon
there's a bouncer right side of the
infield low ranging way over
and his toss in time to gibson to
complete a one two three inning
in fact gibson is retired five straight
joey gallo will lead off the bottom of
the second rangers trailing one to
nothing
he hits this ball a ton way out to right
field
that is gone well maybe he doesn't need
any help
joey gallows 22nd home run of the year
and he's tied the game at one and that
one left in a hurry
109 plus miles an hour off the bat for
joey
this one lined to right field and hicks
keeps his
good vibes rolling now seven for 13
in a rangers uniform
and he went too far in casey mize
notches his first strikeout
of the day it closes out the texas
second
one two picks there's the swing and a
miss and rogers
strikes out one away so two out nobody
on gets into scope and he hits another
one
deep in the hole at short backhanded
neatly by izzy the throw
is a good one and in time and scope is
the fight allowed in the inning
junior candelario struck out his first
time up
candelario drives one to deep left field
way
back in left and that ball is gone
chamber candelario finds
his home run stroke that
has been long overdue his first bomb
since may 18th and the tigers
are back in the lead
he struck him out boy they work well
together don't they gibby yeah
eisen rogers gallo who blasted a 440
foot home run his first time up to right
center
that ball is pounded again deep out to
center
gone gallows second home run of the day
he's having his own private home run
derby this afternoon
23rd of the year somebody's got to tell
joey
you got to wait a few days for that but
when joey gallow is hot like this it's
almost like he's in a different world on
a different planet
tied again at two short has struck out
five times in this series already
2-2 from gibson and did he go
yes he did it's a sixth strikeout of
short
one away
the other way and a base hit for harold
castro that's what he does
this one on the ground but we'll get
through into right field that's a base
hit rangers
had shifted a little bit gallop comes up
going to third oh and they have gunned
down
castro another brilliant
defensive play just a laser of a throw
from
gallow and that's out number two
hit a gap the 2-1 a bouncer to third
culverson off balance throw not going to
get bad dude that's an infield hit for
akil badu
tigers have runners at the corners
[Applause]
and delivers there's a hard ground ball
but right to the second baseman white
over to first the sides retired no runs
three hits
a big assist by joey gallo and two men
left
that pitch count is low enough to where
could at least get
one more inning beyond this one well
that helps right there to take care of
haas
strikeout looking two away
[Applause]
and to check swing no he did not check
it up andalario strikes out a one two
three
for kyle gibson you gotta go throw your
stuff and throw it for strikes
he did it there and he punches out eli
white for his second strikeout of the
day
show you that he's capable low with a
sinking fly ball to center zach short
goes out and makes a spectacular
over-the-shoulder grab ran a long way
for it cracked it well and hauled it in
oh and a diving grab made by short
that's two
in the inning this time he steals a base
hit away from joey gallo
mazara off the handle that's gonna drop
into some fair ball
and a leadoff single for nomar mazara
here
in the seventh for detroit
castro pops it up shallow center that's
gonna drop
second hit of the night for harold
castro the tigers
have a couple of men on
oh high and tight and rogers will take
the walk
that's it so the end of the first half
for kyle gibson right there
what a first half it was we'll see if
the bullpen
can keep it 2-2 aj hinge goes to his
bench
miguel cabrera thought he was getting
the day off not so fast
off the glove of rodriguez
they they don't get cabrera on
everybody's safe tigers have the lead
3-2
now jonathan scope the 2-2
fly ball right
field gallow trapped it that was a fair
ball
jonathan scope comes through and harold
castro scores to make it four to two
now robbie grossman here's the payoff
what a good at bat
great bad great take two bases
loaded walk another run for the tigers
in a 5-2 lead here in the seventh
one-two pitch a swing and a miss
struck out candelario and the inning is
done
tigers lead three but importantly they
scored three and they now
lead five to two
this one lined out to center field
that's a base hit
brock holt pinch hitting for culverson
this one out to center field that is a
base hit
and so the rangers have the first two
men on and the makings
of a potentially very interesting inning
here
this ball hit hard out to right field
that's a base hit
rangers have him loaded in the eighth
inning
still nobody out happy birthday
nathaniel
aj hinch wants his all-star gregory soto
comes on
for the meat of the texas order in a
tough spot
i think we're looking at a
semi-intentional walk here halt white
and low out there and there is
paul foreign got a walks
and that makes it a two-run game holt
scores from third everybody else moves
up a bag
now two he struck him out blew it by him
at 97 for the second out of the inning
the sign in sets no balls two strikes
bases loaded two outs the pitch swinging
in a mess he
got him on strikes gregory soto does the
job back-to-back strikeouts of
hicks and jonah heim
2-2 and that one that's a fair ball
karim's off the side of the stands out
into short left
and abanya's in the second with a
lead-off double
[Applause]
the 2-2 he blew him away
first career 2-winning save for gregory
soto tigers win their third straight
series
they beat the rangers 5-3
to wrap things up here in arlington